kenny a lot of folks have seen the video
the other night when we were doing our
show and you opted
at the beginning of that show to say i'm
going to support the players i'm a
former player
and and walked away
and we're cool with it what are your
thoughts now on on
what uh the feedback was and and how you
felt about doing that well
i wasn't worried about feedback i was
just worried about what i felt was right
you know i said it before as a black man
and as a former player i just thought of
that this was an opportunity to not just
sit and and talk about it but actually
join the march
and so i joined the march by walking out
here that's what it felt like it felt
like i was participating in something
bigger than basketball bigger than the
moment bigger than
me talking about these players at the
time so i just felt that that for me
personally that's how i felt um i think
that you know
we are in a not a an interesting time of
a war against humanity it's you know we
it's not just racism it's a war against
humanity because if the things that were
happening to anyone
we would all look at that consumption
production or distribution of that hate
that we're seeing spewed upon african
americans if we saw that on
across border against anything we would
all be
you know flabbergasted and i think that
as an
african-american man as a black man i
understand that and i've seen it too
many times
where i just continued to talk about it
so
and i think it was important to take
action and
i always give sports analogy my kids
always if we got a second
i i it's almost like if you're at a at
us at a school
and there's only one school in town
right and you're going to this school
and they say anyone who's late to this
school gets thrown out to school you're
gonna get thrown out
and then you realize that there's a
group of kids that's always late and you
go well we don't throw you out to school
but then you do your research and you go
oh well wow that bus
doesn't leave on time for them to be
there you know what they don't have
wi-fi
in their area to even tell them that
this these are the systematic things
that we're talking about
this is oh wow they don't even have car
you know what we're going to put a large
where you can't even
buy a car so now you look at that school
and they go oh wow we didn't realize
that now if you still continue to do
that
after you know that these things are in
place then we know it's personal
and it's not about everyone it's a
collective movement to get that group
and the last thing about that is then
when that bus goes by
and that time someone wants to throw a
rock at it you go why are you upset
that's why you're upset good to have you
back with us tonight
good to have nba games back and we'll be
back with more in just a minute